Thank You mr. speaker and at the Prime
Minister I know understands the
frustration from those most at risk when
they see a report like that and they
know action is needed and actually is
needed now not in a few weeks or months
so can I ask the prime is just complete
well perhaps the Prime Minister will
indicate whether that's all of the
action or whether there's more action
this is a serious issue we could make
progress together and but it is
important that it's done swiftly for
those most at risk Mr Speaker I want to
turn to the overall numbers of those
that have tragically died from Kovach 19
because those overall numbers haunt us
since last Prime Minister's Questions
the government's daily total figure for
those that have died from coronavirus
has gone past 40,000 the ons figure
which records cases where coronaviruses
on the death certificate stands at just
over 50,000 and the number of excess
deaths which is an awful phrase stands
at over 63,000 these are amongst the
highest numbers anywhere in the world
last week the prime minister said he was
proud of the government's record but
there's no pride in those figures is
that mr. speaker let me just say that on
the death figures for this country we
mourn everyone and we we grieve for them
and for their for their relatives and
their friends but I must also tell him
and he's raised this point repeatedly
across the across the dispatch but the
best scientific evidence and advice is
that we must wait until the epidemic has
been through its whole cycle in order to
draw the relevant international
comparisons and data I'm afraid I'm I
simply must repeat that that point to
him and as for the what this country did
to fight the epidemic I must say I
strongly disagree with the way he
characterizes it I think it was an
astonishing achievement of the NHS to
build the Nightingale hospitals I think
it was an astronomer
that this country came together to drive
down to follow the social distancing
rules in spite of all the doubt that was
cast on the advice to follow those rules
to get the number of deaths done to get
the epidemic under control in the way
that we have and this government has
announced a plan and on May the 11th to
get our country back on to its feet and
that is what we are going to do we are
followed we have a plan we're following
it and we're going to stick to it